https://www.youtube.com/subscribers Voilà, c'est le dernier carton.
Ok, bah je vais le descendre.
Oh wow !
Quoi ?
Mais vous êtes un génie !
Non, je suis témoin de Jéhovah,
vous avez deux minutes à m'accorder ?
Ah, non!
Non, je peux pas là.
J'aide un ami à déménager.
J'ai vraiment pas le temps.
Non, mais oui je suis un génie !
Le fait que j'apparaisse d'un coup comme ça,
c'est un indice en fait !
Et, vous êtes connu comme génie?
Je veux dire,
c'est quoi votre nom ?
Serge.
D'accord.
Et du coup, j'ai 3 voeux alors ?
Non.
J'ai le droit à combien de vœux alors ?
Zéro.
Mais Aladdin par exemple...
Put**n Aladdin.
Aladdin c'est une lampe à huile !
Et alors ?
Lampe à huile = voeux
Et lampe de poche = est-ce que tu préfères ?
Est-ce que tu préfères quoi ?
[sifflement]
Je vais t'en faire un facile
pour commencer.
Est-ce que tu préfères un t-shirt rouge,
ou un t-shirt vert ?
Un t-shirt rouge.
Ok.
Ah ouais...
Parce que ça se réalise ?!
Ah ben oui, moi je suis génie à la base.
T'es pas en train de jouer
à action ou vérité avec ton petit cousin.
Et si je veux pas jouer ?
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Bah, tu meurs.
Ah,oui...
D'accord.
Ça  rigole pas, hein, le règlement ?
C'est pas le règlement
C'est juste que tu me réveilles
alors que je me suis couché il y a 2 heures.
Et si en plus tu commences à pinailler,
je te défonce.
Alors...
Est-ce que tu préfères...
un doigt au mileu du front
ou un bras, mais au milieu du ventre ?
Pfff....
Heu...
Un bras au milieu du ventre.
Ok.
Abracada"bras" !
Bon, est-ce que tu préfères...
entendre les pensées de tous les gens que tu croises,
ou que tous les gens que tu croises entendent tes pensées ?
Bah, entendre les pensées de tous les gens que je croise.
Ok.
*Connard,connard,connard,connard,connard,connard...*
Quoi,c'est marrant !
Ok.
Est-ce que tu préfères
Ah, t'as cassé la lampe.
Non,non je l'ai réparée en fait !
*Ouais,ben tu ferais mieux de réparer ta vie*
En tout cas c'est hyper sympa d'être venu nous aider.
Ben c'est normal,on est amis.
*Ah mais on est pas amis toi et moi*
*J'avais juste besoin que tu portes mes cartons*
Alors...
Est-ce que tu préfères...
t'évanouir quand tu réponds à une question,
ou te faire gifler quand tu poses une question ?
M'évanouir quand je réponds à une question
T'es sûr ?
Ouais.
Ca me fait marrer à chaque fois ça.
C'est chiant,
c'est très très chiant.
Est-ce que je peux changer ?
Non,tu peux pas changer.
Mais pourquoi vous m'avez frappé là ?
Parce que... tu m'énerves.
Alors,est-ce que tu préfères...
Qu'est-ce que se passe si je détruis la lampe ?
*Bah ça annule tout.*
Bah rien.
*Merde.*
Abracada"bras" !
Ça y est, j'ai fini !
Ah,bah merci,c'est cool !
Ouais.
Par contre tu feras attention,
il y a un faux contact sur ta lampe de poche.
Bon, assieds-toi parce que tu vas prendre cher toi.